if you plan to travel by plane
anywhere in the united states you're
gonna have to provide identification
several times now of course that's
racist but what's interesting is that
requirement does not apply to illegal
aliens today the director of the tsa
admitted that hundreds of illegal aliens
have been allowed to board airplanes
just by showing their arrest warrants
he admitted that while being questioned
by senator josh hawley of missouri who
joins us tonight senator thanks so much
for coming on thanks for asking that
question how can i get on a plane by
showing my arrest warrant now
yeah well apparently you can tucker i
mean here's the thing it is utter and
total contempt that this administration
is showing for the law-abiding citizens
of the united states what they're
telling us is wait in the longest lines
ever be treated to all kinds of random
inspections and invasive procedures and
have your stuff confiscated but if
you're an illegal alien and you have
committed a crime oh and you have an
arrest warrant come right to the front
of the line and get right on the plane
and as you said the tsa administrator
told me today that maybe a thousand such
illegal aliens just this calendar year
alone have been able to use their arrest
warrants to get on planes it is
unbelievable and fly free at a time of
rising fares so i know you're a
lawmakers this may make you
uncomfortable why should i obey the law
again
well i mean that's exactly the message
the administration's sending is that if
you obey the law basically you're a
sucker i mean this is this is the
message to law-abiding citizens that
you're scum you do as you're told you
stand there you wait but oh no if you're
a criminal hey we're fine with that
because they want to normalize crime
tucker they want to normalize illegal
immigration they want to normalize
rioting they want to normalize all of
that stuff and and here we have it my
favorite part of the hearing tucker was
when the tsa administrator said to me oh
we're only concerned about people who
might pose a risk to to flight you know
i said being a confirmed criminal and
having an arrest warrant isn't a risk in
the air and he just looked at me blankly
he said oh well that's that's not our
problem
apparently it's the american people's
problem
why are none of these
undocumented migrants being flown to
martha's vineyard i checked this
morning.03 percent of people martha's
vineyard arrived from another country
there's no diversity there whatsoever
none so why aren't they going there why
are they going to central pennsylvania
you know i think the answer is tucker
because liberal leaders are always for
their policies for someone else you know
they don't want you to be able to buy
gas but they want to be able to fly
around in their private planes they
don't want you to be able uh to they
want you to have to follow the law but
they're not going to follow the law they
don't want to have to accept any illegal
immigration or illegal immigrants in
their communities but of course they
want to send them to everybody else's i
mean that's the real truth here and
we're seeing it all over the country
it's the latest example
we need a massive airlift to aspen and
we're gonna do a whole show on that soon
because i think it's a really good idea
we need to decolonize aspen i can't wait
senator holly great to see you tonight
thank you so much
thank you
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight